Innan detta så ville jag inte.
Ja fan innan detta tänkte jag att jag ska inte hamna i den diskussionen.
Men nu ställde jag frågan.
Kan du inte bara få...
Ja det känns som ett återkommande tema den här podden, att du alltid har en sak du inte vill ta upp på den, men den kommer upp.
Men är det så, nu gick vi in, du ska få berätta lite om dig själv, men jag bara hoppar in här lite.
Man sa det omsökt 160 miljoner.
Kan du inte ta...
Du vet...
Vem är du typ?
Det låter inte så jävla verkligt.
Du har rejändes framord.
Ni har inga syra kolleger, ni bråkar aldrig, och det finns inga tviga ögonblickar.
Ja, nu kanske jag får skit för detta, men jag säger...
Jag håller med.
Men, vad brinner ni mest för?
Då välkomnar vi Henrik Hoffman-Kraft till podden Make Sweden Stronger.
Dels är du ju premiäravsnittet för den här säsongen, men du har ju också ett jävligt behagligt namn.
Du låter som en tennispelare från 80-talet eller nånting.
Har nån sagt det till dig?
Vet du vad?
Det är nog första gången jag blir introducerad, nu har jag knappt varit med på nånting i poddväg överhuvudtaget i mitt liv, men överhuvudtaget introducerad som Henrik Hoffman-Kraft, för kraft är min frusnamn och vi är relativt nygifta och jag har gått mer under Henrik Hoffman tidigare.
Jag förstår.
Men gud alltså, en 80-tals tennispelare vill väl alla vara han liksom.
Hehehe, jag kallades allt för Rybakov förr, för de tyckte jag såg ut som en ukrainsk höjdhoppare, men hehehe, men jag tycker Henrik Hoffman det har något artistiskt över sig.
Ja men det är snyggt, snyggt.
Kan vi inte få lite kort om dig som person, vi behöver inte gå in på du vet, barndomen och sådär men bara.
Nej men kort om Henrik Hoffman är att han väl hela cirkuleringen.
Ska vi snacka Henrik Hoffman i tredje person hela podden?
Jag tycker vi ska göra det.
Oh weird.
Och nu hörde du det, jag tog bort kraft.
Ja vad fysat.
Nej men jag kommer från en småstad med företagare och föräldrar, småföretagare och föräldrar och det har väl alltid haft en stor inverkan på mig i allt från att jag, alltså låt det vidrigt klyschigt men jag älskar att jobba, driva bolag.
Jag ser det, alltså när jag varit anställd så har jag oftast inte sett mig som den kanske moderna anställde ser sig i att man bara har sina timmar att göra utan jag på gott och ont alltid nästan vill att driva de här bolagen som jag jobbat för med de som faktiskt driver dem liksom.
Det är jag, tidigare har jag varit på Babyshop Group som vi så vackert hette efter ett tag när vi hade förvärvat alldeles för många bolag och så vidare.
Det är väl jag då och så driver jag Dema idag.
Det kanske vi kommer in på lite länge.
Exakt, jag tänker att vi ska komma in på Dema där.
Men du har varit på Babygroup, var du delägare i det på något sätt eller kom du in där?
Nej, det var jag aldrig.
Jag hoppas att det är officiellt okej att jag säger det.
Annars är min nuvarande delägare Marcus, han var där och startade det med sin påvarande fru Lynne.
Men jag fick möjlighet att köpa in på lite lite optioner i slutet där så att jag hade lite grann, men väldigt lite.
Men var det ett av de bolagen du kände att du var med och försökte driva?
Kände du frustrationen där över att vara anställd så sen startade ni ihop eller hur?
Varför började du driva eget istället?
Ja, men 100 procent.
Jag kände verkligen att jag drev Babyshop ihop med Marcus och Lin, som var ju grundarna, men också ledningen i form av Nick, som var CFO, som jag jobbade nära under mitt management tre nio år.
Och sen Jonas som var CMO och flera med dem.
Jag älskade det, det var många sena kvällar, även när jag jobbade med mer growth, eller vad man vill kalla det, med retention och performance och allt möjligt, så satt jag ändå på kvällarna och snackade med Nick, och CFO, han är lika långdragen som mig, så det kunde bli långa kvällar med många detaljer och så vidare.
Man vet, man vill göra saker i ett bolag även om det inte är ens uppgift, om du förstår vad jag menar, man vill hänga på lagret.
Jag lyssnar på din podd och älskar att höra när du, när man hör hur du ska vara med, eller det kanske jag har skrivit på LinkedIn, ska vara med på leveranser ibland upp till kirjorna, eller vad jag nu läste eller hörde.
Så där var jag också, trots att jag bara var en av alla anställda.
Men det har ju sina baksidor, då helt plötsligt kräver man ju mer.
Och det var ju ingen som bad mig att vara så där engagerad, alltid kanske.
Så jag kan tänka mig att det är en jobbig person att ha som anställd.
Med tiden så vill man väl driva eget om man är som mig kanske.
På den tiden, för Dema är ju mer av en plattform, vi ska komma in på det men är det verkligen det man drivs av när man, ni körde ju Babyshop och det skalade ju ganska fort och det blev ett rätt stort bolag liksom och det hände mycket som du sa, en del uppköp och liknande.
Jag tycker att det är lite fascinerande att man gick från den resan till, nej nu ska vi bygga en plattform med siffror.
Är det verkligen det man saknar?
Är det det man tycker är det roligaste på resan?
Ja det är bra fråga.
Nej, siffrorna var ju det vidriga med hela resan.
Det var ju det som aldrig, eller vet du vad, i den största delen av resan så funkade inte det.
Sen, jag var inte kvar lika länge som Markus var kvar, jag vet inte exakt sådär.
Jag sa det till mig själv innan den här podden, att jag borde kolla när jag slutade, för det är pinsamt att säga fel år när man slutar.
Men jag tror att det var 2009 när jag började sluta.
Men 2019, då började vi ha riktigt bra koll på grejerna och vi byggde ju verkligen inte Dema som Dema är idag, men vi byggde något typ av light inhouse då.
Och det var vi ju en av många som gjorde.
Alltså, många av de lite större snabbväxande e-handlarna i Sverige då hade ju en liksom, låter boomeraktigt men en dataavdelning.
Om du papper vad jag menar, det är data engineers, det kanske är data scientists, de kanske inte riktigt ser sig som det men det är väl typ det de är va.
Och analytiker och så vidare liksom.
Problemet är att det blir extremt dyrt, det blir ingen skala på det, allt man bygger är bara för sig själv.
Och man har alltid för lite data, trots att man är stor.
Man har alltid för lite data för att modeller ska bli riktigt kraftfulla.
Så siffrorna och det där är i alla fall aldrig nånting jag tyckte var det roligt, utan jag tyckte det var bara att exekvera och testa och se när det händer saker.
Dra ut ett mejl till en miljon personer och sen höra hur kundtjänst skriker för att man har gjort något fel.
Eller det blir kaos på lagret.
Det kanske inte var mitt fel, kanske var nåt annat, men man har en alldeles för aggressiv rabatt.
Så sakerna bara flyger av hyllorna.
Och sen kommer CFO'n några veckor eller några månader senare och skriker på en för att man har bara sålt allt i minst marginaler.
Jag gillar att det är det roligaste.
Ja nej men alltså det är ju faktiskt när man har kanske ångest och ibland det kan bli, ärligt talat, ledsen på sin arbetsplats när man får skit.
Men det är ju, då är man ju med.
Exakt.
Då händer det grejer, då är man med.
Och det är inte liksom, jag lägger 20 timmar på att göra någonting 1% mer, bättre, annorlunda.
Utan det är de stora liksom, vingslagen eller jag vet inte vad det kallas.
Men ja.
Kan du inte ta oss med därifrån till liksom idén till, ni byggde liksom ett Dema Lite som du säger, och jag har hört lite andra poddar från dina medgrundare och så där, men kan du berätta hur idén växte fram på riktigt när ni tog fram liksom första idén kring att det här kan bli en affärsidé typ?
Ja men förenklat så byggde vi, vi avrundade lite och förenklat så byggde vi ett Dema Lite på Babyshop back in the days.
Vi kunde, för att göra det väldigt konkret för de som lyssnar, så kunde vi bidda på GP3 och Profit LTV på Google.
Det är jättetidigt, såpass tidigt som Google hör av sig själva och säger att det är ni och Zalando eller någon i Europa som gör det här.
Så avansierat, men bara ändå i den här Lite versionen.
Sen går vi alla vidare, det är inte exakt samtidigt, men låt oss säga att vi alla tre går vidare.
Markus, jag och David då.
David är väl hjärnan bakom Dema Lite.
Han är också hjärna kanske bakom Dema.
Men han är i alla fall Lite hjärnan.
Men vi går alla vidare, vi gör lite olika saker.
Jag konsultar, typ inom samma bransch och gebit, och jobbar med tillväxt för e-handlare bland annat.
Och David gör väl samma sak, under egen låda frilansar och Marcus sätter sig mest på bänken och pustar ut lite efter 15-20 år som e-handlare.
Han investerar lite biter i C-bolag.
Och sen, jag vet faktiskt inte riktigt hur det här hände, men David är ölkontakt, Marcus bodde i USA med sin dåvarande fru då.
Och jag och David pratar om att starta ett bolag, lite mot Demahållet men kanske lite annorlunda faktiskt.
Och vi kommer ganska långt med den idén och sen så säger David från liksom, vad fan Marcus har det avsett med att jag har en jävla dunderig idé här liksom.
Vi borde, ja, det var inte namnet, det fanns ju inte så beva, men vi borde bygga Demah Advanced, eller vad man ska kalla det.
Och på den vägen är det, det var liksom 2022.
Där och då var det ganska lätt att få kapital för en startup.
Vi hette ju demah.ai när vi började, det var innan LLM och ChatGPT.
Det kom ju sen där på hösten tror jag.
Men det var ju inte någon jättedålig timing för oss.
Så...
Det var ju fint att det kom.
Men ja, nej så där började det och sen satt vi ihop det här ganska, liksom det blev ganska snabba puckar.
Vi insåg att fan det här måste vi göra, det här vill vi göra.
Tog in en första utvecklare som konsult, som nu är anställd och det är jag väldigt glad och tacksam över, att han har varit med från start och sen så kom en till och en till och en till och sen kom den första beta kunden.
Ja, jag vet inte om det där var kanske mer en historisk genomgång än en förklaring varför det hände eller?
Nej men det är väl, det känns som att det ofta är så, när man har varit med och drivit någonting som verkligen har växt upp, då tar man en paus och så blir man konsult under något år eller två, det känns som att alla blir konsulter, och sen tröttnar man och så drar man igång någonting som var ett problem när man drev senaste bolaget.
Jag tror det är det mest hälsosamma entreprenörskapet faktiskt.
Jag har drivit ett bolag tidigare som var inom en bransch som jag aldrig hade varit inom, och det var ju bara, allting handlade bara om att jag skulle ställa frågor hela tiden om hur den faktiskt fungerar och vad kunderna egentligen tycker och tänker och sådär, alltså det är väldigt mycket mer trevligt att driva ett bolag där jag förstår hur våra kunder, hur vidrigt det kan vara att vara liksom en, vadå, CCO, CMO, performance marketer, e-handelschef, när siffrorna inte går som det ska och man ska driva lönsamhet, samtidigt som man måste driva topline och man har inga bra siffror och sådär, jag vet hur det känns.
Jag bara tänker, jag har ju hört dina kollegor nu prata om DEMA och de har haft några avsnitt här i framtidens e-handel till exempel, men då hamnar de alltid i det här MMM-snacket och vad det är egentligen.
Och jag har fortfarande inte fattat vad DEMA gör och jag gissar att vi är typ såhär era kundgrupp, alltså det finns väl många som är era kundgrupp.
Men jag, vad fan, vad är plattformen på riktigt?
Om man ska verkligen konkretisera vad plattformen är, vad gör den?
Ja, ja jag tar till med det här, det här är feedback direkt till mig för jag ska vara den som ska ha satt det här.
Jag tycker att det alltid varit så himla svårt, men vi är inte nödvändigtvis någonting som historiskt har funnits.
Jag skulle ändå säga att vi kan hävda att vi är bättre än konkurrenterna därute, men vi har ändå konkurrenter idag och det börjar bli lite mer så att man...
Gemene bolag har inte bara ett BI idag, utan man har någonting som är mer plug and play, mer fokuserat på att stödja budgetallokeringen i form av marketing, att stödja besluten med, ja egentligen, vilken produkt man ska försöka sälja, var, när, hur.
För att optimera både Sells Thru och liksom GP3 eller Contribution Modern.
Men så det vi är, om vi ska ta bort MMM-delen och det här med measurement och det där va, för det är faktiskt så vi ser det internt också, om man ska liksom köra lite navelskåderi så har vi ett core och sen har vi en measurement-del.
Och vår core, den är ett extremt mycket starkare BI för din kommersiella verksamhet, för de som ska driva tillväxten.
Det går snabbare, det är en vassare beslut och du kan ta, alltså du kan ta fler beslut.
Och sen så har vi vissa sådana automatiseringar så att du behöver inte ens ta besluten när du har satt upp regler.
Till exempel om hur du ska styra din feed.
Om det ska göras på en kombination av lageromsättningshastighet, marginal och vad du har för prediktad profit LTVI på vad dina produkter säljer.
Men finns det en problematik här i att för vilka är era kunder, det måste vara ganska stora bolag som ska fatta detta.
För i ärlighetens namn så är det en sån människa som jag går in och säger ja det här är en produkt vi tjänar pengar på.
Det är typ min beslutsprocess när jag lägger pengar på det.
När du diskuterar så är det väldigt tydligt att det är någon som verkligen förstår språket som ska sitta med detta.
Vilka är era kundgrupper, vilka är det ni riktar emot?
Du har helt rätt och det här är väl därför, det här är anledningen att jag ligger sömnlös om nötterna.
Men vet du vad det är väldigt spännande här, för du är ju precis som Markus och så många andra entreprenörer och liksom vd'er som har varit med under en längre resa i ett bolag och inte bara kommer in och blir vd för ett miljardbolag.
Ni har ju känslan ner på den minsta varianten.
Är det här bra eller dåligt?
Ni nästan känner det i magen om det här kommer att bli bra.
Ja, för ni ser snittkvitt åt, ni ser en fulfillment-kost framför er.
Men när man skalar och det där inte kan vara att du ska ta alla de där besluten, då måste det till att sådana som jag ska kunna ta de besluten.
Och jag fattar inte det.
När produkterna går från någon hundring i antal, till några hundra, till tusen, till några tusen och sen har du flera marknader, då blir komplexiteten, givet att varje liten order har en egen resultaträkning, men som samtidigt ska hopplas ihop på något sådär rätt sätt.
Det ska lira med din kassa och din balansräkning är stort och att du ska leva genom hela säsongen och inte gå torr på bästsäljarna för tidigt, för då konverterar du ingenting på din gratis direkt trafik som du förtjänat genom all SEO, som till exempel junk-companyet alltid har byggt upp och sådär.
Alltså, du vet, hålla ihop det här, det är väl liksom det som är nyckeln.
Och, nej, alltså våra konkurrenter, vårt största konkurrent är i någonstans status quo, att du fortsätter att skala med ett liksom halvdålig GA4-uppsättning med något BI-verktyg som alltid är någon månad eller några månader lite för sent i sin vidareutveckling.
Du som, nu är det nästan som jag sitter i ett möte med dig och pitchar, men det är väl du som vd, grundare eller, ja, sådär va, vi kan säga det.
Men du kan ju hantverket och produkten och orderna och du förstår alla BI-dashboards och så vidare.
Men din performance marketer som spenderar 10-20, ja, vem vet om någon har 30 kanske också, procent av försäljningen i marknadsföring och helt avgör vad vi kommer sälja idag, imorgon och nästa vecka.
De är inte där inne i din BI.
Oavsett hur mycket du har lagt upp på din klick, och jag har sett hundratals klickuppsättningar som är fantastiska.
Men de har ju brutalt låg usage.
För det är ingen som orkar se in där.
Men det är vackert när man tittar på vad man kan se.
Ja men det förstår jag menar va.
Så där är vi inne och grottar.
Och då har vi någon form av nedfrånskrig här i vår go-to-market.
Att vi måste förklara för dig varför du ska lägga mindre tid i din GA4, i ditt BI, i dina sheets, i det ena med det andra.
Vad betyder BI?
Det känns som att i den svenska marknaden så är det BI, det är ju business intelligence, men i den svenska marknaden så är det Power BI som alla tänker på.
För det är Power BI eller Click man har i Sverige.
Men i andra länder som jag kommer i kontakt med så finns det väl lite andra tools som har mer penetration.
Men de är ganska lätta att komma igång med låg maintenance-kost för att bara koppla ihop några Exceler eller en datapunkt som finns i sådana BI-konsulter som kan hjälpa dig och det är inte så dyrt, det är 5-10 000 kronor så kan du sätta upp en dashboard som uppdateras automatiskt.
Men vi har ju varit där och jag har ju suttit med dem där, jag fick inte någonting av det alls och jag fattade beslut om att skicka det där maillet som sen gjorde att jag kunde avgöra om en Babyshop-månad gick med brakförlust eller var break even för att jag kanske skickade fel diskant.
Siffrorna fanns ju tidigt i våra BI-rapporter och det var ju fina styrelseunderlag.
Alltså styrelser inom e-handeln har ju alltid nästan haft ganska bra underlag.
Men det är ju för att, du vet, Excel-personer kan sitta och konsolidera data och så där men det är ju vi som gör jobbet.
Det är ju vi som sitter med e-mailen eller med Performance eller Visual Merchandiser på sajten.
Det är vi som gör jobbet och vi måste ha datan lättillgänglig.
Ni måste koppla ihop där.
Jag hade ett snack med Samir på Juni.
Ja, de lånar ut pengar till e-handlar och liknande men när jag satt och lyssnade med honom och vi snackade, då hade ju dom 800 olika produkter de kunde göra i sin produkt.
Och då var min fråga ungefär samma.
Blir det inte bara jävligt mycket?
Hur vet ni vad ni ska dra gränsen för?
Vad ni ska göra?
För när du beskriver det här så pratar du ju ganska brett.
Hur vet ni vad ni ska sälja in till kunder eller vad ni ska sluta utveckla och vad ni ska tjäna pengar på, vad som bara blir en till funktion som ingen använder?
Vem avgör det liksom?
Ja, det är ju den stora frågan inom vår värld.
Som ska serva e-handlare så är det liksom, dels så ska man lyssna på kunder såklart.
Vi lyssnar ju väldigt mycket på våra kunder och de har ju nästan en del av alla utvecklingstimmar så lagda till att kundrequest, för vi tror ju någonstans att det kommer sedan skala fint mot resten av marknaden.
Men sen handlar det om den visionen vi har.
Det kommer jag ihåg när jag skulle upphandla system, även om det var inom mitt gebit, när jag har satt på BabyShop till exempel, ett nytt CRM-system till exempel.
Jag visste ju inte bäst inom CRM-system och vad jag borde ha.
Jag visste hur jag maxade det jag hade och gjorde det bästa av saken där.
Så det handlar ju om väldigt mycket för oss att vara väldigt så in the forefront och verkligen förstå vart det går och så vidare.
Där är det utvecklingen går och vad som kommer att driva värde för slutkunden.
Där är det tillbaka till att det där som du sa att man startar upp ett bolag med ett problem man hade tidigare, att vi har den magkänslan.
Vi känner den djupt i mavgruppen om det här är någonting bra eller om det här är en, som det är mycket nu, en AI gimmick som investerare tycker är sexigt, men som en handlare i slutändan kommer känna, vad skrämmer det där till?
Jag sitter fortfarande och jobbar GP3, vad ska jag göra med en, nu säger jag inte att allting är AI gimmicks, och vi har ju AI delar också.
Men där är det väldigt tacksamt att ha den bakgrunden skulle jag säga.
Du kan snacka samma språk också.
Ja, precis.
Sen blir det väldigt lätt för mig att tappa fotfästet också när jag har suttit och pillat i DEMA och hjälpt våra kunder i x antal hundra timmar, att då gå till, ja men säg att jag går till dig och bara, ja men såhär kan du göra och sen så, du vet, pratar jag jätteport och visar såhär jättemånga saker snabbt och du förstår inte vad du ska ha någonting till så att, ja det är en utmaning faktiskt.
Ja, hur funkar det?
Fördelen med att sälja en hantel är ju att det är en jävligt enkel säljprocess.
Behöver du en hantel så googlar du en hantel och så köper du hanteln.
Det är liksom inget.
Jag gillar ju det, jag drivs ju av det.
Men när man säljer en sån här produkt då som, som är så mycket större, alltså vi har väl alla försökt köpa tjänster eller plattformar på nätet och så får man en demo och så går man in i någon jävla demo och så klickar man runt och så har de skrivit gymkompaniiet längst upp så att det ser ut som att den är personlig och sen så gör man så i 20 minuter.
Jävlar vad trött man är på det.
Ja, hur säljer man, hur jobbar ni med sälj liksom, hur får ni tag på kunder?
Ja, alltså för oss så handlar det väldigt mycket om relationer och det börjar oftast där för jag håller med dig, det finns liksom tusentals system därute och än en gång tillbaka till när jag upphandlade CRM-system.
Jag jobbade med CRM 60 timmar i veckan och bara köttade och det var ingenting annat som fanns nästan i mitt liv.
Men inte visste jag om fler än fem CRM-leverantörer i världen.
Men det finns ju hundratals.
Så det handlar ju om att man ska ha nöjda kunder som rekommenderar en vidare.
Det är ju liksom A och O.
Vi har events också.
Det handlar om att prata med smarta personer som dig och liksom komma under ytan lite.
Vi har ju kunder som under en säljprocess som några möten känner att, men vi tror på er.
Och sen så är det såklart att, men du vet, de har väl någon uppsängningstid och de kan ju liksom säga upp det om de inte tycker det är bra, men de signar på och de har sett en del under demo-säljprocessen så vidare.
Men det handlar om att de tror på oss.
Och därför vill vi liksom, vi vill ju vara framförallt gamla operatörer, eller liksom handlare, eller från branschen som verkligen förstår de här grejerna.
Men är det så ni försöker komma in på liksom, jag bara tycker det är intressant, försöker ni bli i kontakten med olika konsultbyråer då som jobbar med att typ hyra ut e-handelschefer och liknande, är det den vägen man går, eller går man direkt på företag?
Det är en super relevant fråga och det är lite både och sådär.
Vi har ju några sådana konsultbolag i Sverige som vi tycker att vi, vi båda gillar varandra så att säga, de driver liknande frågor, de tycker att vi är en bra plattform, tack vare att de har en kund som har valt Dema, så har de börjat jobba med Dema och så tycker de att det är bra.
Det är ju super, för många frågar sina konsulter om är det här någonting som du tycker är bra.
Sen har du ju också, tyvärr, så är det så att alla inte alltid har bra relationer med sina konsulter, så att konsulterna pitchar in någonting behöver inte alltid vara det bästa.
Men typiskt sett, det får ju ringa på vattnet om man har en bra produkt, om man levererar på det man lovar.
Men man måste ju ta det lite back to basics och förstå kundernas behov och sådär.
Nej, det är ingen som googlar på ett DMA, för vi kan ju knappt säga vad vi själva är.
Men det är väl någonstans liksom en e-com omni analytics-plattform i coren och sen har vi measurement on top och sådär.
Men vem fan skulle googla den grejen?
Så det är ju snarare liksom, det är lätt att snappa upp de som har tillväxtproblem eller de som har problem med sin profit till exempel.
Och sen står allmänt bara mun till mun med nöjda kunder i starkast jämt.
Och vi behöver ju inte som du, vi behöver ju inte samma volym va.
Så mun till mun är ju så mycket lättare när det handlar om B2B på något sätt ändå.
Alltså att du ska klara hela din omsättning för att jag köper en hantel och säger, och om någon anledning skulle säga att jag är, alltså jag vet inte varför jag ska gå runt och prata om mina hantlar, är det mera på vad jag menar.
Men du vet om du träffar, om du sitter i podden och pratar med Johan från HSNG och så säger han, jag använder det och jag tycker du kan kolla på det.
Alltså det är ju allt som behövs.
Och sen har du och jag en konversation.
Jag fattar.
En helt annan fråga.
Ni har ju tagit in pengar och ni förlorar ju en del pengar.
Folk får gå in på alla bolag och kika där.
Men fan, vad är det som kostar så mycket pengar?
Det är...
Är det firmafester?
Ja exakt.
Du kan se våra firmafester.
Nej, men det är väl kanske den frågan jag älskar att få svara på.
För det kostar...
Jag menar alltså helt ärligt.
För det kostar extremt mycket att bygga ett riktigt bra, robust analysverktyg som faktiskt kopplar ihop data.
Vi har liksom...
Vi har väl ungefär 20 stycken utvecklare.
Och det är utvecklare som har suttit på alltså Nasdaq, OMX och den typen av data engineers.
Har ni den sloganen till kunder att vi tar kostnaden så du slipper?
Är det det som...
Nej men någonstans...
En learning från BabyShop var ju att det drev ju helt plötsligt en hälsosam GP3 av alla de här insatserna.
Men overhead blev ju för stort.
Det är väldigt svårt att sluka det du behöver sluka som ett miljardbolag för att bygga ett gammalt lightens.
Alltså det behöver ju en, två åtminstone data engineers, sen behöver du nog en två data scientists.
Och då har du inget fint urväxt så det är inte nöjligtvis så att någon kommer att använda skiten.
Kanske bara ett tabeller.
Ja men du vet, det bara fortsätter ju.
Utveckling, det kostar och det tar tid.
Hur störande är det att, för jag gissar att ni kopplar ihop er mot allt typ som man har.
Och sen så bestämmer man någon sorts regelverk eller vad man vill.
Är det så det funkar liksom?
Ni går in i, ja.
Hur mycket hatar ni alla, liksom skillnader i landskapet, att nu ska allting gokki godkännas.
Är det sådant som påverkas er, eller GDPR sparas, får inte göra på det här sättet, eller analyticsbyter, uppsättning, typ.
Är det en grej eller kan ni bara skita i det, för ni går direkt på sajten?
Det är ju en av anledningarna för att det har kostat.
Vi är inte beroende av det G4.
Vi gör ju dig också, mer eller mindre, oberoende av ditt, att du är väldigt compliant med GDPR och knappt får någon tracking.
Det är den här hela measurement-delen.
Vi kan ju säga till dig varför marknadsföring du ska investera i, även om du har jättedålig tracking.
Så vi kan hjälpa gymmekompaniet att förstå värdet av vad ni skulle faktiskt få ut, om ni börjar pusha lite mer meta till exempel.
Nu hamnar vi i den här jävla diskussionen ändå, men jag frågar ändå bara, varför kan ni göra det?
Ja men det är jag istället, det är då går vi till ämne med.
Innan detta så ville jag inte, ja fan innan detta tänkte jag att jag inte ska hamna i den diskussionen.
Men nu ställde jag frågan, kan du inte bara få, som en treåring, som att ta en treåring.
Ja det känns som ett återkommande tema den här podden, att du alltid har en sak du inte vill ta upp på den, men den kommer upp.
Den kommer upp med Ella.
Nej men du, så här är det, då går vi till statistik.
Så det är inte så att jag kan, när jag inte följer varje klick, att jag helt plötsligt kan säga att, Joel såg den här annonsen och sen så köpte Joel tack vare den annonsen.
Nej, det kan jag inte säga.
För jag har ingen aning om att det finns en Joel.
Det jag har en aning om, det är att du över tid höjer och sänker investeringar i marknadsföringsinsatser, låt oss kalla det det.
Det kan vara en typ av kampanjer inne på Meta eller Google, så det är inte så att Meta är en sådär.
Det kan vara en typ av radioreklam, tv-reklam, whatever.
De här insatserna, investeringarna fluktererar.
De går upp och ner.
Outputen fluktererar också.
Det är din försäljning men i vårt fall tittar vi mer på GP3.
Det gör att din discount-effekt som är så svår att hantera i allt det här med attribution, var det discounten jag körde nu eller var det att marknadsföringen gick bra, den så att säga neutraliseras ganska mycket i det hela.
Jag är inte statistiker, jag har väl bara läst 7,5 hk på InstaStick, men som jag tror att det är så är MMM en multiregressionsmodell.
Man tittar på alla de här input-
och output-variablerna och sen så ser man förenklat då över tid, för då tar vi in, säg ett, två, tre års data och så batchar man ihop det på dag, dagsbasis eller veckobasis.
Och då ser man över tid vad som faktiskt ger någonting.
Vad som ger någonting direkt och vad som ger någonting direkt men har en mycket längre så kallad adstock-effekt.
Typiskt sett en tv-reklam kan ju ha en effekt över längre tid för att folk då tickar ju inte direkt uppenbarligen men har sett över en tid och sen så går man in 20 dagar senare och köper sin antal.
Eller vad det kan vara.
Och då kan man koppla ihop det.
Och sen så finns det, och det är ganska populärt nu också, incrementalitetstester, geolifttester eller liftstuddist.
Det här finns lite olika namn för det.
Och det är mer eller mindre förenklat, ads, världens A-B-test.
Så det blir mer kaosalitet och inte korrelation på storskal utan det är kaosalitet.
Du sänker eller höjer spänden för en grupp och behåller det samma för en annan grupp.
Sådana grejer har vi också.
Så kan vi kaosalt säga att det ger dig väldigt lite att bidda på ditt brand name.
Det är en typ exempel, enkel, low hanging fruit man alltid kan göra.
En incrementalitetstest på till exempel.
Hur funkar er plattform då i realtid och uppdaterar sig själv löpande och så läggs det in i någon sorts statistik eller måste man alltid kolla på historisk data?
Det är det som gör att vi behöver börs data engineers.
Så en visit nu är en visit i vår plattform nu.
En order nu är en order nu.
Alltså det är realtids data.
Så det är en helt annan värld än det som kallas batch data.
Och sen är det vissa saker vi inte kan få i realtid.
De här kronor spenderat till Google och Meta till exempel.
Alltså de plattformarna är så stora, skulle de serva hela världen med realtids data så skulle det inte fungera.
Så det får vi liksom gårdragens siffror.
Okej, men det är ändå en okej fördröjning.
Ja, vissa bara, men det är ju realtid.
Realtid är ju liksom millisekunder.
Du sa här att SETEG är ett brand name och bidda på det är en low hanging fruit att kolla igenom till exempel.
Man kanske inte behöver lägga...
Ja, man kanske inte får tillbaka det.
Men finns det några fler sådana här grejer som ni ser när ni går in i e-handlare att bara fan det här, det här var ju skit liksom.
Vi har ju kanske framför allt klädesföretag som kunder.
Sedan har vi gymgrossisten och proteinbolaget också och smarta saker som var på podden här nyss också.
Men om vi tar bort dem, bolagen, och tittar mer på klädesföretagen som nästan by default, om de inte är stora retail-kedjor, så är de i väldigt många marknader väldigt snabbt.
Det gör ju att du har hundratals produkter och sen så är det olika verkligheter i varje marknad ner på din GP3 och din GM3 per produkt.
Och när du får en snabb överblick på det, det är Low Hanging Fruit.
Då kan du ju ta bort väldigt snabbt produkter som du faktiskt förlorar pengar på.
Så du bara bränner pengar.
Och det svarar inte ens upp till en kassa flödes positiv effekt ibland.
Utan den är faktiskt så negativ på GP3 att den inte försvarar även när man tar bort kogs-effekten.
Så det skulle jag säga är ofta en Low Hanging Fruit.
Och då kan det vara en marknad som faktiskt ser bra ut för det här bolaget.
Men på grund av returen, returkostnader, customs, what have you liksom, default shipping, alternativet är alldeles för dyrt eller någonting du vet.
Så är det liksom, då är det 5, 10, 20 produkter som bränner pengar i det landet och de är oftast lite för populära de här produkterna liksom.
Så det ser bra ut i din ROAS, det ser bra ut i dina försäljningssiffror, du når landets targets, men det är bättre att inte nå de targets då ju, och faktiskt lägga de pengarna på andra produkter i det landet, och bygga en hälsosam omsättning i det landet, eller att skifta spend på de produkterna och lägga det i ett annat land där de faktiskt kanske inte bränner pengar liksom.
Ja men jag köper det och vi säljer till exempel till Danmark, och vi säljer ju mycket skistänger, och det är en sån typisk, alltså en skistång, det kan se ut som att vi har hygglig marginal på en billig skistång när vi skickar den till Danmark, men frakten till Danmark är ju helt bedrövlig för en skistång, eftersom det är en skrymmande produkt och redan där är vi liksom back på den skistången, så det är ingen idé att sälja en skistång till Danmark.
Det är en flustaffär liksom.
Exakt, va?
Och där tycker jag det är så många e-handlare som, alltså, jag tycker GM1 är liksom ett satyg.
För den är bara liksom en, du vet, en potential.
Det är ingenting man borde liksom faktiskt titta så mycket på.
Jag gillar det, GM1 är en potential.
Det är en bra mening.
Ja, men för det är det ju ofta, liksom, har du inte en GM1, men då är det ju väldigt svårt.
Men det är så många som sådär följer sin GM1, nästan som att du vet att man har ett mål på GM1.
Jag har aldrig riktigt fattat det.
För den ger ju väldigt lite i slutändan.
Då kan du väl följa din discount-procent, om GM1en ska vara någon typ av proxy för om vi discountar eller inte, eller följa fullprisordrar eller något sånt där för att driva upp betalningsviljan och sånt där.
Men annars så är det ju snarare en GM2 eller en GP3.
Ändra M-et, men hellre P-et va?
Alltså kan du ha en GP2 per order och titta på det lopande, eller en GP3 per order och titta på det lopande och sådär.
Men det känns som att det är väldigt många som är där idag, så det är inte så att jag tror att det är någon jätteinsight, men jag tycker ändå att det är för många som tittar på sin GM1 så ofta.
Ja.
Finns det någon mer sån här?
För det är ju faktiskt ett jävligt, vad ska man säga, det är ett enkelt tips även utan det med att fundera lite på vad man har för produkter som...
Ja men som man går bak på på olika marknader, det kan man ju ibland bara tänka ut rent logiskt, även utan om man bara är lite insatt i sin egen affär.
Men har du några mer sådana här, fan det här upptäcker vi när folk börjar använda vår plattform, att det här är ett vanligt...
Ja en sak jag upptäcker ganska ofta är att, alltså det är väl ganska accepterat inom e-handeln, om vi liksom inte tar med fysisk handel men e-handeln, att låta algoritmerna jobba med så stora målgrupper som möjligt, med en så stor del av ditt inventori som möjligt och så vidare.
Det där finns det ju verkligen klavertramp att göra eller, om jag ska prata lite mer positivt så finns det low hanging fruits.
Det vi ofta ser är att du har alldeles för olika produkter i samma fid.
Och det här är oftast inte ett problem i bolag som inte säljer kläder, för man har inte en sån GM1 att börja med.
Så jag känner att de icke-klädesföretagen är ofta tvingat att vara med i inter-details med varje order och siffrorna sådär.
Men att du kan ha dina acessuarer, sig strumpor eller kalsonger i samma kampanj med samma fid som du har byxor och tröjor som kanske kostar fyra, fem gånger så mycket.
Det brukar ofta kunna leda till att du helt plötsligt spenderar bara på strumpor och kalsonger.
Om det är väldigt attraktiva strumpor och kalsonger.
För då helt plötsligt så är det de som syns, de konverterar snabbare, det är feedback loopen, tillbaka till Meta och Google och sen så bara tar det fart där.
Och sen helt plötsligt så är du ett kalsongföretag i Danmark.
Din kår i jeans och tröjor, men nu i dina feeds utan att du märker det, utan att du tänker på det.
Så är du bara kalsonger och strumper och eftersom du inte riktigt håller koll på det där i detalj, kanske exakt vad som säljs till varje marknad utan, ja, och då ser det bra ut i roa sen kanske.
Du kanske har en bra försäljning, toti, men det blir dålig profit och det blir en dålig balans i säljrum och du bygger inte dina kumkorter som du vill för du är ett accessoire-bolag.
Eller du får ett dåligt ård i värde och en hög fraktkostnad per order men så tänker du inte på det, utan du tänker bara, fan vad höga frakter jag har.
Ja exakt, de säger bara, det är något dåligt med Danmark.
Bara, ja, det kommer kanske från din feed.
Jag gillar det, jag har mer, mer.
Ge oss.
Ja, och en annan sak, två andra grejer skulle jag säga.
En sak är bara såhär, det här är inte omöjligt utan det ena, men att de som pushar säljet i bolaget måste ha en mycket, mycket lättare feedback loop i hur din inventory, liksom sell through, ligger till.
För det finns ingenting värre än att du dundrar ner i botten och säljer slut på saker för tidigt i dina ads.
För då liksom algoritmerna hackar upp sig, du har ingen perfekt ersättare, du vet, det är en direkt trafik, har ingenting att konvertera på för det där var en bästsäljare och så vidare.
Så den där tycker jag, den är alltid en sån grej som jag brukar vara med och tipsa och visa och sådär.
Och den sista grejen som jag tycker är slående.
Är det okej om jag bara hoppar in där och poängterar det?
För jag är inte säker på att alla är med på exakt vad du menar, men vi har det problemet jättemycket eftersom vi köper in rätt stora, alltså vi måste alltid köpa en container av varje grej vi köper in.
Och då kanske vi får in 400 bänkar av en viss sort.
Det binder rätt mycket ordervärde, vi måste trycka ut dem för vi kan inte ha 400 bänkar av en sort.
Och då får man ett ganska bra tryck på 200 bänkar.
Och sen är det ganska lätt att av själva farten säljas ut de andra 200 också.
Och sen ligger man då tom på lager i tre, fyra månader och sen börjar man om.
Det har varit mycket mer lönsamt att höja priset med 200 spänn och sänka maktnadsföringen lite och så balansera det.
Ja, och någonstans där, och det här är helt omöjligt för de som jag representerar, känns det som, det är growth-teamet på e-handelsbolaget.
Det är helt omöjligt för dem att hålla koll på allt det här.
För i alla fall ska jag liksom, nu har det äntligen börjat ta fart på de här bänkarna.
Ja men nu tar jag helg och jag har inte den här klumpen i magen längre.
Men då börjar det ta en jäkla fart.
Men jag tänker inte på det nästa vecka.
För då har vi bra försäljning på dem och det driver lite allmänt resultatet i bolaget.
Då tittar jag på andra problem.
Så det jag gör då är inte att, så att säga balansera ner här.
Vi pratar inte inköp, vi kan få sina signaler från en annan håll och så vidare.
Men det handlar ju om för mig då, att faktiskt där och då kunna agera proaktivt.
Det måste man oftast automatisera.
Men liksom, där och då börjar det bli överhettat.
Så vi bör nästan ta det åt sidan lite och spända lite mindre på den där kategorin nu.
Något sätt måste vi ombalansera här, för vi vill inte gå tomma sen.
För då, som du säger, då bygger vi i en konsistens i heller.
Att vara i din bransch, att vara en bänkleverantör.
För då är det som att jag, då är det liksom, det låter väl väldigt nästan otrevligt, men då blir man ju nästan ett överskottsbolag med att man bara, nu har gymkompaniiet bänkar.
Och sen ser jag någon jävla kampanj, där har man någon kampanjdrivare och att man hittat en bulk någonstans.
Men det är inte egentligen er, är er, Nej men du har helt rätt.
Utan att du bara tar fart.
Men det är fruktansvärt lätt att fastna i den fällan och, och dessutom så är det rätt krångligt att få igång marknadsföringen igen, upp till den nivå som den ska vara.
Så det är lättare att skruva upp och ner än att trycka på start och stopp.
Det är så mycket, ja, det är helt sant.
Det är så mycket lättare att skruva ner och skruva upp.
Eller, för att det tar för mycket tid så man gör det inte.
Men det är ju så mycket bättre för den själva momentumet i bolaget, att skruva ner och skruva upp, än att starta och stoppa liksom.
Och det är så många som bara liksom attackerar det här problemet på inköpssidan.
Vi måste snabbare köpa in och så där.
Och det är ju bara en del av problemet, för att man vet aldrig vad som tar fart för snabbt.
Och man kan liksom inte predikta sig till alla inköpen i rätt tid.
Plötsligt så kan du inte, du har lagt ordern, vad ska du göra då då?
Alltså då kan du inte bara, ja då måste du liksom den sidan av businessen ta det.
Men en sista sådan tips som jag tycker är riktigt low hanging fruit, som många kan agera på snabbare, bättre och enklare tror jag, med vissa grejer.
Vi har ett EMA sådär men som inte är namnetvis unik.
Och det går nog att ta fram på olika sätt i driftbi eller vad man sitter med Alexander.
Men det är en bättre förståelse för säsong.
Och där känner jag spontant att där är det typ exempel, jag kan tänka mig Joel på gymkompaniiet har en sån jävla magkänsla för det.
Men den magkänslan, exakt vad som är i säsonghjuls nu och hur vädret spelar in och så vidare, skalar ju otroligt dåligt utanför dig själv liksom.
Och den är ännu värre inom kläder och tänk dig med personalomsättningen på många av de här bolagen, det är två, tre år och sen är det en ny person på platsen eller Gud förbjuder.
Du har en byrå som ska få sköta alla de här besluten och de har sin personalomsättning bara i ditt konto, så att säga.
Alltså förståelsen för säsong och de här olika beroendena och vad som är en bra GP3, GM3, ROAS, Profit ROAS i de olika säsongerna och det kan ju vara sent augusti versus sent september bara.
Alltså det slår ju om jättemycket och där tycker jag att att ha den year over year datan på ett bra sätt med lite sådana prediktiva modeller ger väldigt mycket.
Ja, jag köper det.
Vi går ju in i, vi kallar det för löpanssäsongen nu.
Så vi började ju köpa in för några månader sedan för att man vet att det drar igång nu.
Medans då kan man tänka att all motion går dåligt på sommaren.
Nej det gör det inte.
Cyklar går av på sommaren av någon jävla anledning.
Så att de ska ligga.
Alltså det är inte alltid helt logiskt utan man måste vara med några år om man inte och det är ju verkligen tråkigt tycker jag.
Mycket med den här branschen att vi har den personalomsättningen vi har ofta på många bolag.
Tredje året när en person på performance marketing verkligen börjar känna i bolaget lite mer vad som borde funka, vad som inte borde funka.
Det här är något skumt.
Även om det kanske på i-level ser oko ut, men det är någonting skumt här jag måste gräva vidare.
Men då har man ju som e-handlare eller retailer oftast ganska svårt att hålla dem kvar.
Då förlorar man dem och så förlorar man det där liksom.
Så bibehåll kompetens helt enkelt.
Fan Henrik vilka jävla tips du klonkar in de sista 20 minuterna.
Vad glad jag blir.
Då är det skitbra.
Ja, jag ska tänka på dem.
Skitbra ju.
Jag tänker att vi ska stanna av det.
Jag tror inte vi kan pika från det faktiskt.
Ett enormt tack för att du var med i podden.
Det är jag som ska tacka.
Tackar väl.
Jag gillar det, GM1 är en potential.
Det är en bra mening.